une semaine maintenant après la visite
de m6 perd aussi à taiwan la chine
annoncé ce matin qu'elle met fin à ses
manoeuvres militaires mais qu'elle va
tout de même continuer de patrouiller
régulièrement la région du détroit de
taiwan et se tenir prêt en cas de combat
ma faim de points à l'instant sur la
situation avec benoît hardy chartrand
vous êtes chercheur associé à la chaire
raoul dandurand professeur auxiliaire
également à l'université temple à tokyo
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors il ya clairement une escalade des
tensions entre la chine et taïwan et
avec ce que vient d'annoncer la chine ya
toujours un risque d'invasion à l'heure
actuelle
évidemment que le risque est toujours là
et c'est ce que pékin veut faire savoir
non seulement à y voir megan entre états
unis encore aujourd'hui le bureau des
affaires taïwanaises qui est une agence
qui fait partie du gouvernement chinois
cette agence là où ce bureau des
affaires taiwanaises a rappelé
aujourd'hui que la chine était prête à
tout un crime en la force pour récupérer
taiwan dans son giron alors clairement
ce message qui veut qu'ils veulent
envoyer à taïwan assez de messages de
gens qui n'est pas nouveau ça fait déjà
quelques années que la pression
militaire augmente sur taïwan je ne
crois pas qu'une invasion est imminente
mais compte tenu des tensions qui
existent actuellement compte tenu des
capacités militaires très important de
la chine c'est évidemment une éventuelle
une éventualité à laquelle de tout le
monde doit être prêt et puis la chine
qui a publié aujourd'hui son livre blanc
sans quelque sorte de marche à suivre
vers la réunification avec taïwan qu'est
ce que vous en répondrez
m'écouter ce livre blanc là c'est un
c'est un document qui est publié assez
régulièrement nos soins par la chine
mais également par plusieurs
gouvernements publie ce genre de
document là c'est une marche à suivre
c'est un peu pour donner une idée de
décès de ces plans de sa stratégie à
suivre pour l'avenir aussant dans le
document qu'il ya une certaine
impatience par rapport à tout ce qui se
passe au togo taiwan ont sauvé
d'impatience par rapport à la position
américaine parce qu'on considère les
amériques et les américains comme étant
vraiment ce qu'ils font augmenter la
tension dans la région dont vraiment où
le blanc mais rejetée sur les états unis
pour pour la crise dans laquelle on se
retrouve en ce moment d'ailleurs les
renseignements américains qui affirment
qu'il n'y aura pas d'invasion avant au
moins deux ans donc qu'est ce qui
pourrait être fait d'ici là pour trouver
un terrain d'entente à ce que c'est
possible on trouvait d'ailleurs un
terrain d'entente je vous dirais que
c'est extrêmement difficile parce que
les positions de tous les camps ou
plutôt en fait les positions des deux
camps principaux c'est-à-dire taïwan et
la chine sont à peu près conciliables
pour taïwan une réunification était
absolument impossible à envisager non
seulement pour le gouvernement mais
également pour la population on le voit
très bien dans l'est dans les sondages
d'opinion que la très grande majorité de
la population on parle d'environ 90% de
la population qui ne désirent pas une
réunification avec la chine alors que
pour lachine c'est un bus et c'est une
idée qui fait tout à fait consensus non
seulement dans la population mais au
sein du gouvernement qu'on doit
éventuellement ramenée taiwan dans son
giron alors tout ce qui peut être fait
pour l'instant c'est vraiment peut-être
ça soit entre les différentes parties
pour trouver un genre de modus operandi
pour aller de l'avant parce que
officiellement les positions sont
beaucoup trop éloigné pour qu'on puisse
les rejoindre un jour oui entre-temps
déjà toutes ces tensions qui ont des
conséquences en la chine qui sait en
train de retirer des négociations sur
les changements climatiques avec les
états unis c'est majeur parce que c'est
inquiétant pour vous oui absolument
c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète
depuis déjà plusieurs années c'est à
dire que même avant la crise actuelle
avec taïwan le dialogue avait beaucoup
décliné entre la chine et les états unis
ça commençait déjà cinq six ans lorsque
trump avait été élu et si cette relation
bilatérale continue décline actuellement
et vous avez parlé de la fin de la
suspension de la coopération sur les
changements climatiques mail à tous et
toutes sortes de sujets de problèmes sur
lesquels la chine et les états unis ont
cessé de parler alors ces tensions la
ont toutes sortes de conséquences sur le
multilatéralisme sur la stabilité
internationale fut l'amant et quel
pourrait être le rôle du canada dans
tout ça
écoutez ça fait déjà quelques années que
le canada veut jouer un rôle plus
important en asie ça remonte même où
moment harper on sait que l'asie est la
région dans laquelle une région qui
devient de plus en plus importante
politiquement mais également
économiquement le canada a des relations
assez bonne avec certains partenaires de
ses partenaires dans la région dont le
japon mais le problème c'est que les
relations entre le canada et la chine ne
sont pas très bonnes à l'heure actuelle
depuis déjà quelques années alors ça
rend le rôle du canada peu plus effacé
ça rend sa tâche beaucoup plus difficile
en ce qui a trait à tenter d'avoir une
influence positive sur cette crise ouais
alors un dossier à plusieurs facettes on
disait déjà des conséquences alors on va
évidemment continuer de suivre ce qui se
passe de prêts à taïwan et en chine
alors je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à la chaire raoul
dandurand professeur également étudiant
à l'université temple à tokyo merci
beaucoup monsieur abdou chartrons
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit